so today's question is why do startup
entrepreneurs sleep like a baby
I'm Patrick baby your host of item and
weekly and is it just me or do you also
struggle when people say I slept like a
baby last night to reference as if they
slept so well because I have two kids
and let me tell you you know how babies
sleep this is what babies sleep like
they wake up every other hour because
they have what diapers are they pooped
or they just need to wake up to be burp
or they just want to make sure you're
there but they're going to wake you up
every other hours so when people Silas
slept like a baby I don't understand
what that means but I can tell you
something
entrepreneurs most of them do sleep like
a baby do you know why because they're
always up tossing and turning thinking
what the hell did I get myself into when
I decided to start a business what was I
thinking about how am I going to make
this business I've never been in this
business before I've never been in this
industry before I'm not as good as my
competitors can I really pull this off
what about the unknown I'm running out
of money I should have kept my job my
family's not supporting me all of these
things that goes through a startup
entrepreneurs mind that keeps them up at
night all the time but do you know why
entrepreneur becomes an entrepreneur do
you know why do you know why somebody
says I want to go out and be startup
entrepreneur do you know why when you
think about the word entrepreneur what
words comes to mind think about it yes
we can think about business we can think
about job creator but entrepreneur is
linked to word risk
it's risking what I currently have for a
potential bigger victory in the future
right an entrepreneur is innovative
maybe they have an idea and an agenda
that want to sell to other people they
have a vision that's what an
entrepreneur is but let me tell you if
you're an entrepreneur and you felt all
the things I just talked about you're
say that's exactly how I feel going to
sleep at night doing this doing that
look this is what I wake up every day as
an entrepreneur whoever I talk to
entrepreneurs have one responsibility
every day you know what that one
responsibility the biggest
responsibility when you catch yourself
doing things that don't make you money
ask yourself what did I sell today
I sell my idea today that I present my
idea today how many people that I sit in
front of today that I go home today
selling my idea to new people if an
entrepreneur it doesn't matter what
industry you're in if an entrepreneur
goes selling their idea to somebody that
day they will go to a pond where they're
going to start sleeping like a baby less
and less and less and they sleep more
like adults which you'll actually get a
chance to sleep six hours through the
night because your numbers the number
you want to look for is your net profit
starts covering your business expenses
and your life expenses when it does sell
for about an 18 month period you
eventually have a business that's
running for you but that's when you got
to still keep on selling on a daily
basis to advance your business to the
next level in order for you to have the
big victory that you're looking forward
to eventually which is becoming
financially free so my message of the
week to you and please be sure to
subscribe and comment on this channel I
like to keep it pretty short so - so
today's question is so so why do
entrepreneurs sleep like a baby okay
let's go back let's go back to record
that the earth a joke by Ronald Reagan
what he told the Russians